so i want to thank the organizers for
organizing
this wonderful conference and inviting
me to speak so this is based on joint
work with david cullen and jacob fox
so i've given this talk a few times
before but it's the first time with both
ben green and terry tell us sitting in
the audience so
this is
all right stuck
okay so about 10 years ago they proved
their spectacular theorem
that the prime numbers contain
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
so this is one of my favorite terms in
mathematics i learned about it when it
was
first announced i was still a high
school student back then and
at the time you know i felt this was
such a beautiful statement
but of course the mathematics involved
was far beyond my understanding at the
time as a high school student
now that i know a bit more mathic i want
to use this talk to
explain to you some of the ideas
involved in the proof of the green tau
theorem
and also discuss our work which
simplifies a key component in the proof
so i first need to tell you about
another result which is
semaretti's term proved in the 70s that
every subset of the positive integers
with positive density contains arbitrary
long arithmetic progressions
so this is a very deep result there are
now several modern approaches
but none of them are easy and it is used
as an important
key input as a black box input to the
proof of the green tau theorem
now the green dot theorem does not
follow trivially as a consequence of
samaritan's term
because we know that the prime numbers
by the prime number theorem
have density decaying as one over log n
so density of the prime numbers is zero
so well as an aside so it's believed by
people of this community
that and their famous conjecture of
erdes
that the prime the density of the prime
numbers alone should
guarantee the existence of long
arithmetic progressions but this
conjecture is still open
even for three terms but that is not the
approach taken by green tell
so instead they use
what's known as a transference principle
strategy and it goes roughly as follows
we start with a set of prime numbers
denoted p
and they embed p in a slightly larger
set
q and for the purpose of this talk you
can think of them as
almost primes or numbers with few prime
divisors okay that's a bit of a lie but
it's a good image to keep in mind for
the purpose of this talk
and p sits inside cube as a set of
positive relative density
the proof in the green tile paper goes
has two parts
in the first step they prove what's
known as a relative samurai theorem
informally speaking this says that if
you start with a set s
so s is placed as q here
and if s satisfies certain
pseudo-randomness conditions
then it has the property that every
subset of s
with positive density should contain
long arithmetic progressions
in the second step they construct such a
superset of the primes
and verify that the superset satisfies
these
pseudo-randomness conditions and for the
second part they credit
the number some of the number theoretic
inputs to goldstein and euderim who are
working on the problem of prime gaps at
the time
so for this talk we'll just look at this
relative similarity theorem
so this in this informal statement what
does
pseudo-randomness condition mean so
green tile required two pseudorandomness
conditions which they called
linear forms condition and correlation
condition
i'll describe in much more detail what
the linear firm's condition is
but the correlation condition is a it's
a slightly more technical condition
that feels somewhat less natural for the
purpose of this problem
and almost as feels like it shouldn't
belong here
now this is an interesting problem in
its own right it's interesting result in
song right
and a natural question that one could
ask is
does it hold under weaker and more
natural hypotheses
right so this relative similarity
theorem you know what pseudorandomness
condition do you really need
to have the property that every dense
set contains long arithmetic
progressions
our main result is that
in fact we can use a weaker version
of green tells linear forms condition
and completely get rid of the
correlation condition
so this is both a simplification and
also a strengthening
of the relative summary theorem which
plays a main
role in the proof of the green tau
theorem
the recap so we saw simulated's theorem
where you start with a
set of positive integers and the
conclusion is that then sets
contain long arithmetic progressions and
relative summary theorem
the in the host set we replace the
integers by some sparse
subset of the integers so this is the
sparse setting
to put our work in some context
you can ask what sort of host set would
you consider well natural candidate is
well let's take a random set as a whole
set
so numbers from 1 to n i pick
each number to be in my set with some
probability
this probability the case within so that
it's a sparse set you can ask well does
that have the property that relatively
dense subsets contain long aps
so this problem was investigated
initially by kohakawa wuchak and roto
and they solved this problem in the case
of three term arithmetic progressions
and they identified the correct
threshold with the correct exponent
for which this phenomenon occurs and
this problem was
solved in general independently by
column gowers and also shocked
where they solved this problem
completely for all k term aps
for us we'll focus on the pseudorandom
case so
we'll prescribe some pseudorandomness
conditions to the whole set
and as i mentioned so in the green towel
paper they required
two different conditions called linear
forms and correlation and will show that
a weaker form of what they call linear
forms is sufficient
to guarantee the relative samaritan
theorem
it does but with the worse uh with the
worst exponent
okay so the first half of the talk i
will describe to you what is this linear
forms condition
but to do this i want to first recall a
proof of ross theorem so ross theorem is
the three-term
case of samaritan's theorem
it says that okay so this is what it
says this is a three-term case
it was proved by ross using fourier
analytic methods but i want to show you
a proof found in the 70s that goes
through
graph theoretic methods and the reason
for showing this proves that there's a
graphic construction that will be very
useful
for motivating the three the linear
forms condition
so okay so the roster is about subsets
of 1 to n
but it will be easier and equivalent to
work instead in a circular group
z mod m so these two objects the systems
are
very similar one difference is that a 3
ap so
three-time arithmetic progression might
wrap around in the z-mod n
uh whereas i don't want that to happen
in one to n and there's an easy way to
get rid of this issue
which is that you embed your one to end
in somewhat larger cyclic group
so that these wraparounds don't occur
and so for so it will be equivalent to
work in a setting of a circular group
and we'll do that from now on okay so
here's
a proof of ross theorem so i construct
for you based on the set a
a tripartite graph ga it has
uh three vertex sex sets x y and z all
of them having n vertices
labeled by elements of z mod n i put in
an edge between x and y
if and only if this expression two x
plus y is in my set
a okay so that's just the rule for
putting in the edges so you can think of
this as a modified kd graph
i put an edge between x and z if x minus
z
is in my set a and between y and z
if minus y minus 2 z is in my set a okay
and so these are the rules of putting in
the edges
now note that a triangle in this graph
corresponds to
these three linear forms o ob in the set
a
and the reason for choosing these
particular linear forms is that they
form a three-term arithmetic progression
with common difference minus x minus y
minus z
so this says that triangles in this
graph
correspond to three term arithmetic
progressions
in the set a but we started out with a
set a
which is free of three aps
so does that mean that the graph has no
triangles
almost not quite there's still some
triangles
namely the triangles corresponding to
trivial three-term arithmetic
progressions those with common
difference
zero so you still see some triangles but
very few
and in particular every edge of the
graph is containing
exactly one triangle namely the one
which completes the equation x plus y
plus z equals the zero
so this is a construction for this graph
ga based on the set a which is 3ap3
okay to recap starting from a we
constructed this graph with
3n vertices 3 and a edges so
from between x and y each vertex has a
edges coming out of it
and every edge containing exactly one
triangle
so there's a classic result of russia
and similarity
that says that in a graph where every
edge is containing exactly one triangle
then the graph must have a subquadratic
number of edges
okay so this is it's a tricky result so
it follows from
uh it's a consequence of what's known as
a triangle removal lemma
using this lemma we
find that the number of edges must be
little o of n squared
so the number of elements in a must be
little o of n
and this proves roth's theorem now of
course
it's a bit of a cheat because most of
the meat of the proof is in
this result but i'm not going to show
you the this result and also
as i mentioned the point of showing you
this proof is that i want to use this
graph construction
on the previous slide okay
so now i'm ready to describe what is
this
relative rost theorem right so the
sparse version of roster
that we have it says that if s satisfies
and i'll tell you exactly what are the
pseudo-randomness conditions that we
need
then it has this relative ros property
that a dense
subset of s well so
it has a particle so i'm using the
contrapositive it says that if it's
three ap
free then it has little o of
s elements okay and so what is the
pseudo-randomness condition
well let's revisit this graph but now
construct a graph
not on a but based on s right so somehow
we know that this graph encodes
the three aps but i okay so again
the vertex sets are z mod n and i put in
the edges based on whether these
expressions are in my set s so this is a
graph gs
and the pseudorandomness condition for
my set s
is the following it says that this graph
gs
can has asymptotically the expected
number of embeddings of this object
k222
meaning that if the density of s
is p then the
the density of embeddings of this guy
should be p
raised to the 12 up to one plus little
one an
error
s is sparse so the the density of s goes
down with n
yeah so that's the whole point because
if s is already dense then it falls from
raw spin
not quite i mean there are limitations
to how far you can push with this
condition
right but for yeah so
okay so
but we need a little bit more just
because of technical reasons we need a
little bit more we need
that not only it has to correct the
expected number of embeddings of k222
but also the subgraphs of k222 so this
guy
has the number of embeddings p raised to
however many edges i've drawn here
and that's the pseudo-randomness
condition that i need
for guaranteeing a relative roster and
that's the version that
uh that we have okay any questions
so you stated the theorem and then it
seems as if is it
do you mean what you said or is there
some extra condition that you have this
i'll state a
somewhat more precise version later on
but this is this is a version that's
that's we can understand that yeah
okay all right
let me try to make some arguments that
this is a natural condition it's a
natural pseudo-randomness condition and
to do this let me draw some analogies
with
uh this classic result of chung graham
and wilson
which says that in graphs of constant
edge density
so they stated several uh quasi
randomness conditions which all turn out
to be equivalent so these are
things like subgraph counts or
eigenvalue conditions or code degree
conditions
uh discrepancy conditions but in
particular there's one condition that
stands out which is that having the
correct
c4 count is sufficient to guarantee
several other quasi randomness
conditions
right so this is a classic result of
theirs however
this these equivalences fail in the
sparse case right they break down in the
sparse case of the density of
edge density goes down with goes to zero
with n
one way to interpret our results
informally is that if we want
some sort of extreme or ramsey type
results about some graph
h so in roster h is a triangle
then we can get these results provided
that there's some host graph
which is pseudorandom with respect to
counts of the two blow up of h
so two blow up meaning i start with my
graph and then i double every
vertex and if you look at chon gram
wilson the four cycle is a two blow up
of an edge
okay so this is just drawing some
analogies to try to convince you that
you know this is a natural condition to
consider
so let me outline the proof of this
relative roth theorem
so so this is basically the version that
we saw earlier
if you have density at least delta than
the set a necessarily contains a
three-term arithmetic progression
there's a standard averaging argument
credited to vernavidis saying that
starting with this result
we can obtain a counting version of
raw's theorem
where we're guaranteed not just one
three ap but many
three ap so quadratic number of three
aps and this is essentially a sampling
on averaging type argument where you
know look at the progression of length
and not and then you find the three ap
and then you do it again and so on
so you get many three aps
so let me show you how to prove raw's
theorem okay so this is
known as a transference principle and
it's featured in green tile's work
starting with a set subset a
of s we're going to find a dense
model a tilde so
my set a originally is sparse but
there's some sense in which
i can find the set a tilde which is
both the dense set and also in some ways
it's a good approximation
for a and this will be in terms of then
something that i'll call cut norm which
i'll elaborate on later on
and they also have similar densities
and furthermore a counting lemma
will tell us that the number of three
term arithmetic progressions
in my original set a appropriately
normalized
will be close to the number of
three-term arithmetic progressions
in this dense model now by
ros theorem which we'll use as a black
box the counting version of ross theorem
we know that there are lots of three
term arithmetic progressions
in a total because it's a dense set
therefore my original a must also have
a lot of three-term arithmetic
progressions and
that's the proof of relative lost okay
of course i have to explain to you you
know what are these two steps these two
ingredients
so but this is the general outline
it will be helpful to oh and by the way
let me say a word about so i've so far
been mostly just talking about the three
term case raw student
so for samurai's term for a k term it
turns out that
if you want to prove summary of this
term it's much easier to prove the
three-term case than to prove the
four-term or longer case
as it turns out for doing transference
or transferring
this result down to the sparse setting
at least the way that we do it there's
no additional difficulty involved
besides notational difficulties so
i'm going to show you how to do this for
the three term case but if you expand
out the notation and make some
minor modifications then you can also
use the same technique
to prove relative simulator but i'll
just
explain what happens to the three term
case
okay so now i want to convert language
somewhat so
instead of talking about sets i want to
go from sets
to functions right so to have a weighted
version of
uh these results so so we saw this
before so this is a counting version of
roster
so that if you have a dense subset of z
mod n then it contains a quadratic
number of three aps
using the counting version of roster we
can deduce a weighted version
where instead of considering a subset a
of z mod m
we now consider a function from z mode n
to a zero one interval
okay so if you're limited to zero and
one then
these two are equivalent but now i'm
relaxing f to take long
values between zero and one and you can
deduce this from this
the first result up to a change of
parameters
so these two are equivalent up to a
change of parameters so we'll use the
weighted version of roster
so this is the dense setting
what does a sparse setting correspond to
so i start with some
sparse host set s and
more generally i'll use some weighted
form which will come in the form of a
normalized measure nu and nu will be
normalized so that
it has expected value 1.
so for example if i start with some
concrete set s then i want to take mu to
be the
indicator function appropriately
normalized so that it has
expectation 1.
a subset of s then would correspond to a
function
f that is measurized by nu in the sense
that it's
less than equal to new pointwise
and this condition of a having relative
density at least delta in s
then corresponds to the expectation of f
being at least delta
so this is just the table of
translations what i said earlier
so we started out originally in the
world of sets and now we're going to
move to the weighted world
where i now talk about functions and
here's the dense setting
and here's the sparse setting and if you
set new the majorizing measure to be
identically one then that's precisely
the dense setting
okay so then a relative roster
which i stated somewhat informally in a
previous slide
now i stated somewhat more formally and
i'll explain what this three linear
forms condition means in a second
but it says that if you start with a
new which satisfies this three linear
forms condition
then every function f majorized by nu
and having expectation at least delta
has
this lower bound on the weighted number
of three aps
and the c can be taken basically to be
the same c up there because
the result transfers over through this
transference argument
everything of course provided that n is
sufficiently large
okay so let me say what this three
linear forms condition is and this is
basically
this thing i mentioned earlier about
k222s
now let me do this precisely so i look
at this graph so this is essentially the
same graph theoretical construction i
made earlier
except that now i use put the weights on
the edges
based on the function majorizing
measure nu that started with and i want
to say that the density of this k222
in this weighted graph uh is somehow
pseudorandom
meaning 1 plus 201 right
so writing it out so if you
look at this graph and i want to count
the
occurrences of this so i just write out
the expressions it means precisely
that this expression is one plus little
one
and the same is true so that's an
additional assumption the same is true
if any subset of these twelve factors
were deleted
all right so this is the precise
statement of our result
no it can be anything that the case
would end so hidden in here i'm assuming
that this
there's some okay so you take maybe a
sequence of these things depending on n
and i want to say that this is something
which the case is zero with that
i mean when you want to then derive the
relatives can already be
uh your assumption on the strength of
the
three and four conditions will have to
be
exponentially strong um
no i don't it depends on how you
interpret it uh but in
at least the way i faced it here there's
no requirement on how fast is the case
right it should be a finite reversion
but if we only get
um relative rough for a fixed delta sure
the little one should be just
doesn't it need to be arbitrarily less
than some threshold right so then you're
asking how large does n need to be
sufficiently large
sure yeah okay so
yeah no but actually the only place
where you have major losses in the
original so however
whatever bound you get for the original
roster or semi-ready term
that's the major source of loss and in
the transference we
only occurred a polynomial amount of
loss because of the arguments used
so are you using as a blood vessel
we'll use roster as a black box
oh well you said i'll explain the
slightness well in what i would present
in this talk we'll use it as a black box
any other questions
okay so so that was for the three-term
case the relative roster
for roth of simulated them there's a
similar k linear forms condition and the
catering uniforms condition
then says that well instead of taking a
tripartite graph now i take
a hyper graph so for k equals to four
i'm looking at a four apartheid three
uniform hypergraph
so essentially things corresponding to a
simplex
and i put in the weights in a similar
manner to how i put on the weights for
graphs
so these expressions are chosen so that
they form a
fourth term ap and each term depends on
only three variables so i
construct some weighted hyper graph and
i want the four linear forms condition
to say that
there's something about the density of
the two blow-up
of the simplex being correct so it's a
natural generalization of what i told
you earlier
except now you have to work with hyper
graphs the notationally it gets a bit
more complex but mathematically there's
not
more difficulty okay
so to answer your questions earlier so
there's
a couple of papers that we wrote so the
initial the where we first found this
result that we wrote up in this
paper that we titled a relative
similarity theorem where we
proved this result through transferring
the hypergraph removal lemma
okay so this is very expensive but it is
uh
a more general result right so
transferring the hyper graphical
transfer means that we assume the
hypergraph removal lemma as a black box
and then we transfer it down to a sparse
relative setting
so this gives a relative sparse
hypergraph removal level
subsequently i found that you can
actually transfer
similarities therm so a modification of
the argument allows to transfer
similarities therm down from the dense
setting to the sparse setting so there
the quantitative bounds on some early
stern can be just brought down to the
sparse
is settings you can see that in a kind
of graphs that come up
in that reduction yeah just by the
analytical proof across
those graphs satisfy a triangular
removal lemma with
a really good bond not with the number
of exponentials but just with a single
exponential
um so can you say your question again
that's true i understand
so it seems to the argument well let's
look at that
so that was actually that was for
motivation so the reason why i sketched
through the summary was to motivate the
graft construction
right but it's so easy then you uh you
just do
so the same argument but not with that
full tripod graph but with some kind of
shoe random
sub graph and then because they're
trying to remove our lemma
is true for the tense graphics so that's
that's this approach right that's this
approach right so
you just need um
okay okay maybe we can talk off the line
yeah um
so in comparison this the
this approach gives a more general
result about hypergraph removal
in the sparse setting and this result
this approach is more
direct now they're not independent so
this paper i like this paper a lot
because it's really short
um but it does quote some a key
fact from a key step from this result so
it's cool so there's accounting limit
which i'll explain and that's like the
main
new advance that we have and this quotes
the counting number so somehow this
doesn't actually contain all that much
new mathematical content but
it's an outline of how to put things
together to give you a very short and
direct
way of getting the relative summary
editor okay
sure yeah it's not self-contained at all
so it's very much not self-contained but
i'll explain
so the approach i'm taking in this talk
follows this outline
okay so i gave a transfer and slide
early on with sets now i'm just giving
the same slides
with functions so i start with f
majorized by nu
so f is some sparse thing and sparse
means that it's
unbounded because of the normalization
and i and there's some dense model
theorem which
guarantees us that you can approximate f
in a certain cut norm which i'll explain
in a second
so that the stance model f tilde is a
dense object so it's bounded
they have the same expectation and a
counting lemma then would guarantee that
these two expressions which are the
weighted
three ap counts they are similar so
and by the weighted version of roster we
know that this is lower bounded
and therefore we have relative rods
there
okay so now i need to explain these two
steps what is
dense model theorem and what is counting
number
okay so let's start with dense model
theorem
so in what sense okay so
you know i said dense models in what
sense does this dense model f total
approximate
the sparse object f less than nu
in the previous approach taken by green
tell they use something which is based
on the gauss's uniformity norm
and the key difference for us is that we
don't use that we do not use the
gaussian uniformity nor instead we'll
use the cut norm which is also known as
discrepancy uh and yeah so
i'll explain what that is in the next
slide the comparison so what is the pro
and con
with a cut norm we get a cheaper dense
model there so it's the same dense
molybdenum except applied to a different
norm
and because of that we require fewer
pseudo-randomness hypotheses
the trade-off where we have the pace and
there's now a trickier counting lemma
and so that's really the new thing that
we have that allows
uh the simplification
okay so the cut norm so if i start with
two
weighted bipartite graphs g and g total
between x and y so the cut norm which is
featured in freeze canon's weak
regularity lemma
says that i say that these two weighted
graphs are close in cut norm
if for every subset a of x and every
subset b
of y let's say if you sum the edge
weights
between a and b then the
sum of edge weights for g is close to
the sum of edge weights for g total
and this is true for every a and b
and so written out it looks like this
that's what it means for two weighted
graphs to be close in cut norm
for two functions on z mod n to be close
in cut norm means precisely that i look
at that graph
that you know we saw many times that was
constructed
for the purpose of illustrating roster
that graph constructed based on these
functions on z mod n
they are close in cut norm right so
that's what i mean by
two functions on z mod n to be closing
cut north so precisely this expression
here because remember
two x plus y is what the rows in the
graph theoretical construction now
this 2 is not important i can erase both
twos because i can just make a change of
variables
but this is the graph that came up in
our earlier construction
and this notion is weaker than f and f
total being close in the gauss
uniformity norm
okay so then the dense model theorem
says the following
says that if you start with a majorizing
measure nu which is close to 1
in cut norm so this is a statement about
pseudorandomness and this is implied
by the linear forms condition that we
had earlier
then the following is true that if f
is majorized by nu then there's always a
dense model f total
which approximates f in cut norm
okay so this is a dense model theorem
okay so it seems a little strange if you
haven't seen it before like how do you
approximate
a sparse object by a dense object
let me just mention the um a bit of
history on this result so
this was used uh in the original green
towel paper and they used some sort of
regularity type energy increment
argument and this result was
clarified in a subsequent work by
taonzigler where they showed that
the primes contain arbitrarily long
polynomial progressions
and afterwards there was a
simplification of this
theorem so a simplified proof given
independently by gowers
and also rango travis and tousani and
madame where
the proof uses so gower's phrase in
terms of a separating hyperplane theorem
whereas rango travis and tussaini
madonna used actually the mini max
theorem and also both in both cases they
had to use the wire stress polynomial
approximation theorem but this is a very
nice and short proof
so this is a very nice and short proof
of the dense model
just the theorem as uh the hamburg yeah
that's the hung
actually so i was looking at them and i
thought this result
gowers only uses the finite dimensional
case of hambanak
which you know it's yeah and well i
think that was actually attributed to
minkowski even beforehand anyways
so so that's the dense model there okay
so
that was this part so of the outline of
the transference result
now i want to talk about you know what
is new for us
that's the counting number okay so what
is our counting number
so first let me review the classical
counting lemma
so a counting number is a result that
says that if you have two weighted
graphs g and g tell them if they're
close in cut norm
okay and for for the moment we'll only
consider the dense setting so g
and g total are both bounded by one if g
and g total are close
in cut norm then they have similar
triangle counts
so this is the classical triangle
counting number
let me show you a proof of it it's quite
short
recall what it means for g and g total
to be close in cut norm
it means that this expression is
small right so if i restrict this
expression to
indicator functions a and b
i can relax these indicator functions to
zero one interval zero one valued
functions right just because this is a
bilinear object so the extrema always
occurs at zero one values
so i can relax it to uh to so this is an
equivalent so these
these two statements are equivalent to
each other so when instead of taking
indicator functions i now take functions
taking 0 1 interval valued
so let me show you that these two
expressions are close to each other i
start with
the expression for g which will be
highlighted in blue
so this is the triangle counting g i
claim that i can swap out
a factor of g by g tilde
and the reason why this step is true is
that if i look at the difference between
the two sides
and i fix a value of z right so just
imagine a fixed
value of z then the difference between
these two sides has precisely this form
so for every fixed value of z the
difference between the two sides
is at most epsilon in absolute value
and if you allow z to vary then they're
still bounded by at most epsilon
in difference that's just one step i
swap out a single
factor by g total now i swap out the
second factor
the same argument applies
and i swap out the third factor and i
see that well i get what i want
right so the difference between these
two sides is at most
three epsilon okay
so that's how you prove the dense
version of the triangle counting number
it's
fairly straightforward and fairly quick
but this proof breaks down almost
immediately in the sparse setting
remember the sparse setting refers to
the case when g is unbounded
and when g is unbounded the first thing
i said about these two being
closing condor because you can look at
that it's no longer true because well
i can only use a being bounded and g is
unbounded i can't use
the cut number anymore so we need
something else
so and we need some additional
conditions on in the square setting
and the sparse triangle recounting lemma
that we give
says the following if you assume that
one of the g's
right so the sparse g is majorized by a
new that satisfies these three linear
forms conditions so this condition about
pseudorandomness with respect to k222
then g and g total and g total is still
a dense object
then g and g total enclosed in cut norm
implies
that they have similar triangle counts
so this is a new triangle sparse
triangle counting level
okay so the proof has a few ingredients
there are many many applications of the
kochi schwartz inequality now this is a
standard
technique in this area as popularized
for example by gaurs
i won't say too much about that right
but i won't bore you with too much of
the details of
repeatedly applying kosher shorts but
okay so that's one of the steps
the new thing for us the new idea for us
something we call densification
which i'll explain on the next slide
and we also need the proof in the dense
case which i explained on the previous
slide
so what is this new densification
technique it's actually quite simple so
you start out wanting to count triangles
okay you apply cauchy shorts
in some manner a few times now cushy
shorts involves
some squaring and squaring gets you you
know double the vertices
right and by the way so the loss so why
we need a three linear forms condition
mostly comes from
the step repeated applications of kosher
shorts
and that's the most expensive step in
terms of pseudorandomness conditions
but after applying koshi shorts let's
say a few times in a few different
places
one place you might end up is this
object wanting to count this four cycle
okay so how do you count the four cycle
here's what we do let's construct this
auxiliary graph
g prime g prime is just to set the code
degree so i put down
a complete graph between x and y a new
graph where i put on the edges the code
degrees
the idea is that even though i start out
with something which may be sparsely
supported
if it's bounded by a pseudo-random graph
the code degrees are going to be much
smoother it's going to be
they're not going to behave nearly as
badly as the
original graph and you can view these
code degrees almost as if you were a
bounded graph
so it behaves like a bounded object it
behaves like a dense object
now looking at this expression here for
the four ap
count
if i integrate out the z primes
then this is just a triangle count in
this new auxiliary graph
where i keep the original at weight edge
weights but i add in the new code degree
weight
so that's the edge weights for the new
graph between x and y
so okay so now i'm back at evaluating
some triangle counts so
at first it seems like we went around in
circles but i want to do triangle
counting
so doing a bunch of cauchy shorts i get
to count four cycles
and this reduces the counting triangles
so it seemed like we went around in a
circle but we gained something really
important which is that one of the edges
now behaves like a dense edge a dense
bipartite graph
now do this two more times right do this
two more times and you convert the
problem
from the dense setting from the sparse
setting
to the dense setting which we already
know how to handle
and that completes the proof well it's a
sketch of the proof
of the triangle counting number okay and
then
putting everything together so i showed
you what this dense model theorem is
about okay i didn't show you the proof
but i showed you what it's about
and then we have this counting them up
putting everything together we get this
relative raw stereo
okay so since the original green tile
work there has been several
simplifications
so cal simplified some of the number
theoretic estimates
that were involved in constructing the
pseudo
the pseudorandom host and the
dense model theorem was the proof was
also simplified as i mentioned earlier
on
and now we are putting some new insight
into the counting lemma so there's been
several simplifications since the
original green top paper
i think would be good to collect them
into one place and so we are
currently finishing up writing an
exposition
of the updated exposition of the green
tile theorem and the idea of that this
will be a gentle exposition giving a
complete
and self-contained proof of the green
tau theorem that could be used for
educational purposes so
it's self-contained with one caveat so
we
okay we're going to assume the uh
similarities theorem as a black box
right so it would not be able to contain
some radius term in
uh in a very short exposition
it will contain all the number
theoretical stuff it will also contain a
number of theoretical estimates
that's right yeah so uh
assuming rudimentary knowledge
okay so coming soon hopefully
um okay so this is my last slide again
with the
statement of result and um that's all i
want to say
so you have to check these linear form
conditions yeah could you say that's
scary if you haven't looked at it how
scary is it
so it depends so if you're if you want
what you want to do is to prove the
green tau theorem then okay so you have
to
first think how do you construct this uh
pseudorandom
superset or the pseudorandom measure
okay so there's there's some number
theoretic work that's involved it's not
too bad so terry has simplified some of
the the since the original green towel
paper and it's not too bad
it's not too bad like it's kind of it's
not too much
you don't even need the paranormal
anymore
so would you say it's significantly
easier to verify your version
of the uniforms condition than it is to
verify that version of the linear forms
condition
i mean there's less things to verify i
don't know whether in retrospect
things are easy once you figure them out
but
i mean there's there's fewer things to
verify um
is it possible that the linear condition
alone implies a decimal ethereum with
respect to the governor's norm
or is it non-counter example um
that i'm less familiar with so
yeah i mean that's that's more i mean
you can look
so galways as a paper explaining the
paper where he gave the shorter proof of
dense small of them he went into some of
the aspects
of yeah i'm not too sure
so you motivated the appearance of the
two blow up okay three very nicely by
saying
but it's something else in your paper
you actually
that the two verb or the triangle is not
exactly what you need
something slightly weaker
sure so the question is so right so
something would have been a very natural
thing but it's actually not
actually so for for triangles you do
need to blow up
is that for other graphs if you want to
do removal element for other graphs you
can do away something slightly like for
triangles you still need it to blow up
yeah for for another graph you can use
like what we call week two blow up where
you save a few of the other edges
but it's a legitimate question the
amount of pseudorandomness condition
okay you definitely need more than
just knowing the triangle counts like
just knowing the triangle counts won't
get you anything
you need more than that and we know that
to blow up is enough so the
the truth it feels like it but i'm not
sure i mean
the truth could be somewhere in between
but it certainly feels like a natural
condition
yeah okay so is there a chance that
this transference principle or even more
generalized transference principle
will enable to boost up the bounds in
the original summary or oscillations
where the idea would be
to start with some not so dense
object and to put it
in a slightly more dense and then
slightly more advanced
yeah that would be very nice wouldn't it
um
i mean i think it's a interesting
direction to consider but
we had some examples which were not i
mean they're not necessarily
counterexamples but they were not
they raised some skepticism towards that
approach but it's
i mean
maybe but yeah i think would be i mean
even for the prime
you know constructing this majorizing
measure is a non-trivial task
and
yeah so in fact the hyper graph removal
version
is it works very well
for any for income
yeah so i forgot to mention that you
know in this
in this outline yeah so in the original
green tile paper they've
they did something which is similar to
this and then subsequently
terry terry tower had a paper that shows
that the gaussian primes contains
conservation arbitrary constellations
and that was more similar to
this approach here right now we took a
lot of the inspiration from
those two works of course
very good